alors est ce que vous êtes confiant pour
la suite philippe douste-blazy
est-ce que vous pensez que dans peu de
temps pourra soigner les principaux 4
kovy de 19 avec le traitement du
professeur à ou est ce qu'il faudrait
pour que le chef de l'état disent voilà
les tests ont été concluants
on va tous faire donc adapter voilà
adopté le traitement du professeur à ou
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait et qu'elle
serait vraiment voilà les échéances j'ai
le temps absolument ce que je voudrais
moi c'est qu' on puisse dans un autre
département ou dans deux ou trois ou
quatre autres départements faire
exactement ce qu'il fait c'est-à-dire un
dépistage massif prendre des cas
suffisamment tôt les traités à la
manière du professeur paul c'est-à-dire
hydroxy chloroquine et un autre des bio
tic qui s'appelle les etr missié mais
ensuite regardé avec un groupe pilote
puisque tout le monde demande ce groupe
pilote placebo qui jean michel aulas
voulait dire quelque chose depuis tout à
l'heure et je veux dire quelque chose
que c'est vrai que vous disiez tout à
l'heure que le le cas raul tu divises la
france antilles boyet les antilles les
poires out mais il y aussi un peu pour
quelque chose parce que lui-même est
devenu un peu un personnage et la
crétine pas s'il a un peu le look du
salon grill aujourd'hui si lui-même tel
lycée pour chercher le monde médical
il a voulu se mettre un port rebellyon
est allé à révéler ce qu'ils ont fait et
on saura bientôt si ils avaient raison
pas et s'il avait raison
ça sera criminel qu'on n'ait pas écouté
plus tôt ça c'est pas moi j'ai une
question à poser assez importante à
monsieur douste-blazy à notre ministre à
notre ancien ministe de la santé c'est
qu'est ce qu'on pense emmanuel macron
puisqu'on sait qu'il a eu des voix là il
a eu des échanges avec le professeur à
où est ce qu'on va aller vers un
traitement de toute la population
avec donc la formule et le traitement du
professeur raoul ou pas on va remettre
d'ici bout ce blazy en place là où on va
on va le rebrancher parce que hier seuls
gens qui posent des questions et ça
c'est la question vraiment qui les
intéresse et on vous on va voir on va
revenir donc dans un instant je vois
donc voilà philippe douste-blazy et là
il est de retour bon rebond soir
philippe sai et pardonnez moi
c'est pas grave alors philippe
douste-blazy je voulais savoir qu'est ce
qu'on pense le chef de l'état emmanuel
macron il sait qu'il a des échanges avec
le professeur à ou est ce que il va pour
est-ce qu'on va peut-être aller vers un
rock on va tester une région puis une
autre puis une autre ou bien est ce que
on va
est ce qu'on a le temps de faire tout ça
parce que mine de rien on est dans
l'urgence
c'est ça la question c'est que je crois
que pourquoi je suis allé immédiatement
apporter mon soutien au compteur à raul
c'est parce que entre rien et un
traitement comme celui là bien
évidemment quand on sait que le virus
s'arrête au bout de six jours ou sept
jours enfonce et on y va
à condition de faire un
électrocardiogramme avant et après et
d'ailleurs sur plus de 2500 cas il a une
mortalité inférieur à 0,5 pour cent
c'est le taux de mortalité de plus bas
en france donc dès l'instant où ça sera
prouvé je crois qu'il faudra en effet le
généraliser alors juste monsieur
douste-blazy juste qu'est ce que vous
répondez aux gens qui disent de toutes
les façons traitement du professeur
house ou pas les patients qui ont été
guéries par la méthode du professeur un
an
franchement aurait été guérie quoi qu'il
arrive parce que oui c'est voilà donc à
plein de gens qui vous disent à qui vous
disent voilà ma mine de rien voilà c'est
juste c'est le fait du hasard iloilo
reggae rico qu'il arrive donc là on
rajoute peut-être des effets secondaires
au niveau cardiaque si voilà si on fait
traitement du professeur en route qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ces jours là
c'est une c'est une vraie question
parce qu'un effet 80% des personnes ont
des formes bénignes
ensuite il y à 15 à 18% de gens qui ont
des pneumonies des pneumonies
mais il faut savoir que il s'est quand
même extrêmement graves il faut
hospitaliser quelqu'un sur ya un
problème pulmonaire et ensuite vous avez
4 % de gens qui vont aux soins intensifs
et cela donc il faut tout faire pour
arriver le plus tôt possible
le problème c'est que vous ne savez pas
à qui vous avez affaire au début c'est
vrai que 80 % de gens s'en serait sortie
avec ou sans traitement mais dans la
mesure ne sait pas qui va aller vers une
complication je pense que le mieux si on
le
encore une fois la menace de manière
absolument évident il faudra le
généraliser c'est ce que je pense